[Musique]
lui clementé bonjour bonjour vous êtes
maire de la ville de cheikh depuis mars
2008 réélu donc en 2014 deuxième vice
président de la cacem vous êtes né en
marié père de deux enfants c'est bien ça
cadre supérieur dans le secteur bancaire
de profession voilà et puis on le
précise vous êtes indisponibilité totale
d'ailleurs vous vous étiez mis en
disponibilité totale pour exercer le
mandat de maire alors précisément luc
louison clémente et vous après deux
mandats vous voulez continuer pourquoi
pourquoi alors que ce n'est plus
forcément très tendance comme on dit
maintenant dans l'opinion publique les
cumuls de mandats dans la longévité
il n'y avait personne à qui vous pouviez
passer le flambeau notre mouvement
politique vivre à schoelcher m'a demandé
de mai vouloir accepter de conduire la
liste d'union aux prochaines élections
du 15 et du 15 et du 22 mars 2020 j'ai
accepté à quelques conditions
la première consiste à dire que s'il n'y
avait pas de rassemblement s'il n'y
avait pas d'unité
s'il n'y avait pas de volonté de
d'ouvrir notre liste que je n'irai pas
comme d'habitude on s'est immédiatement
compris et ses éléments ont été
immédiatement acceptée
j'accepte également parce que il était
question pour moi de faire en sorte à
travers ce que m'a demandé leur chef
cheikh depuis habitué le vivre ensemble
ça compte énormément pour nous au niveau
de la ville de schoelcher mais aussi
renforcer notre mode de gouvernance très
largement basé sur la démocratie
participative
parce qu'en fait un programme n'a de
valeur un bilan elle valeur que s'ils
reposent sur des éléments forts je
parlais de valeurs telles que la
solidarité telles que la liberté tels
que l'égalité tels que la fraternité
salle du sens pour nous à vivre à
schoelcher mais aussi des méthodes de
travail basée sur la concertation et la
participation
je veux également dire que le contrat de
confiance que nous avons passé avec la
population il y a quelques mois quelques
années maintenant été très largement
atteint alors vous annoncez pouvoir vous
appuyez sur un bon bilan de la mandature
2014 2020
1le clémente et notamment au plan
budgétaire expliquez-nous cela écouter
de ce point de vue on peut dire que nous
avons très largement réussi c'est vrai
vous êtes au courant de cela lors de ces
dernières années le gouvernement demande
aux collectivités locales de participer
à l'effort de redressement financier de
la france soit cela a énormément
pénalisé les collectivités locales
telles que les communes notamment
malgré ces difficultés la première
décision que nous avions prise c'était
de ne pas augmenter les impôts pour ne
pas pénaliser donc la dépense qui très
largement entre elles tirent la
croissance laquelle croissance sur
l'emploi
c'est la première grande décision est
notre première décision
aliot responsabilité mars 2020 sera là
aussi de ne toujours pas augmenter les
impôts
ça a du sens pour nous deuxième élément
il s'agissait pour nous de consolider
toute une série de travail qu'avait les
gt1 tab et notamment matière
d'assainissement en matière de réseaux
d'eau potable chez le cher comme vous le
savez l'une des rares villes
une seule vie la martinique a bénéficié
des deux labels station touristique mais
aussi station nautique
ça a du sens pour nous donc fait les
connaît une qualité d'eau de baignade de
toute première qualité
ça a du sens nous avons également
réalisé toute une série de problèmes ce
sera aux évêques sont plaints parce que
concernant comment dire les zones
d'activités qui à mettre en place sur
celle cher ce mantra que joue
aujourd'hui de créer une zone
d'activités 15 alors on va y venir j'ai
l'intention de vous demander un ou deux
exemples de projets que vous avez mais
tout de même
alors effectivement vous dites que vous
vous décerner en quelque sorte un bon
point sur la maîtrise budgétaire sur le
plan budgétaire mais tout de même la
mandature qui va s'achever là elle a été
marquée le clementé par un long conflit
social au sein des services municipaux
alors d'octobre 2010 est à peu près
celle à la fin de l'année 2010 est gardé
en vous des séquelles après un peu plus
de deux ans donc justement ou es ce que
vous avez tout plat
comment dirais-je tout réglé quoi de ce
point de vue là parce que c'est vrai que
ça va durer quand même plusieurs
semaines cette affaire là avec des
conséquences un écoles fermées enfin etc
et vous vous avez dit bah c'est un
conflit qui a pris une tournure
politique et qui n'est plus un dicale
c'est ce que vous avez eu l'occasion de
dire à ce moment là je n'ai pas changé
de ce point de rappeler mans je n'ai pas
changé de ce point de vue une chose qui
est certaine c'est que je ne refuserai
jamais des voies du dialogue
je crois que toutes les fois où un
conflit se pose quelque part c'est qu'il
ya ce que c'est c'est la signification
l'expression d'une volonté d'exprimer de
dire quelque chose donc il faut être à
l'écouté il faut prendre le temps
d'écouter
globalement je n'ai pas de nous n'avons
pas le problème à schoelcher le secret
du point de vue social loin de là il ya
plusieurs syndicats chefferie hier il ya
eu ce conflit quand même il y a
plusieurs qui a duré la ville de
schoelcher est en difficulté avec un
seul syndicat pour les raisons que j'ai
évoquées qui sont purement politiques
alors un exemple de projet emblématique
pour les six prochaines années
mettez le projet phare de la mandature
qui s'ouvre sera l'éducation
il est question pour nous que nous
puissions procéder à la réfection et à
la reconstruction de l'ensemble des
établissements scolaires autour de 4
grands passionnés de commandes hier
d'éducation il est question pour nous
aussi et ça beaucoup de sens pour nous
de faire en sorte qu'une pulsion armés
l'ensemble des élèves de schoelcher qui
quitte le cm2 de tous les éléments leur
permettant de rentrer dans le xxème
siècle apprendre le mandarin parce que
la chine sera la première puissance
mondiale être en situation de parler de
maîtrise la langue des signes être aussi
en situation de prodigué les gestes de
premiers secours
faire en sorte que le numérique soit
bien maîtrisée et enfin faire en sorte
que nous puissions avec eux
réveillé une conscience écologique forte
de telle sorte qu'ils soient les
citoyens de demain porteur d'espérance
pour l'humanité voilà merci le clémente
et d'avoir six ont dû à nos questions
dans cette émission réalisée par édiles
aux curieux clerville merci
[Musique]